vsauce kevin here with a homemade deck
of
52 meme cards to show you
a game that should be perfectly fair but
actually allows you to win most of the
time
how because there's a hidden trick in a
simple algorithm that if you know it
makes you the overwhelming favorite even
though it appears that both players have
a perfectly equal
50 50 chance to win well that's not very
fair what
is fair we can consider a coin to be
fair because it's binary it has just two
outcomes when you flip it
heads or tails and each of those
outcomes
are equally probable although it could
land
on its edge
in 1993 daniel murray and scott teal
posited that an american
nickel which has a flat smooth outside
ridge could theoretically land on its
edge
about 1 in every 6 000 tosses but
for the most part since the first
electrum coins were tossed in the
kingdom of lydia in 7th century bc
coins have been pretty fair as are
playing cards like this deck of
handcrafted meme cards
when you pull a card you either get a
red
or a black card crying carson
it's perfectly binary and there's no way
for a card to like
land on its edge it's either red or it's
black
it's 50 like a snap
from thanos given that is it possible
to crack the theoretical coin flipping
code and
take advantage of a secret
non-transitive property
within this game yes
welcome to the humble nishiyama
randomness game
walter penny debuted a simple coin
flipping game in the october 1969 issue
of the journal of recreational
mathematics and then
steve humble and yutaka nishiyama made
it even simpler
by using playing cards here's how it
works the first player chooses a
sequence of three possible outcomes from
our deck of cards like
red black red and then the second player
chooses their own
sequence of three outcomes like black
black red
and then we just flip our red and black
meme cards and the winner is the one
whose sequence comes up
first so in this example thanks to guy
fieri
player 1 would have won this game
because player 1
chose red black red
here's a little bit of a nitpick because
we're not replacing the red and black
cards after each draw the probability
won't be exactly 50 50 on every
draw because each time we remove one
colored card the odds of the opposite
color coming next
is slightly higher but it'll never be
far from perfectly fair and as we
play it will continue to balance out so
given that each turn of the card has a
roughly equal chance of being red
or black and given that the likelihood
of each sequence of three
is identical the probability that both
players have an equal chance of winning
with their red
and black sequences has to be 50
52 right wrong
and to demonstrate why i've invited my
best friend in the whole wide world
where are you best friend
keanu reeves
okay all right piano you're a little
tall
hold on
how's this okay keanu will be player one
there are only eight possible sequences
that keanu can choose
red red red red red black red black red
red black black black red red black red
black
black black red or black black black
no matter what keanu chooses the
probability of that sequence hitting is
equal
to all the other options for player one
there really is no
bad choice one choice is as good
as the next so let's say that keanu
chooses
black red black great choice there keanu
now that i know
your sequence i'm going to choose black
black red okay now we'll just draw some
cards and see
which sequence appears first
red tommy was so
some red fleck seal action so far nobody
has an advantage
black where are your fingers
[Music]
sad said keanu you should
be sad once you realize that now
there's no way that i can lose
because of having these two black cards
in a row
even if i pull five more black cards in
a row eventually
i will get a red and i will
win irma gerd
ah there it is minecraft
steve has sealed the victory for me
sorry my most excellent dude but i win
because regardless of what player 1
chooses what matters is the sequence
that player 2
picks as player 2 the method here is
very easy i just put the opposite of the
middle
color at the front of the line so when
keanu picked b
rb i just changed his middle r to a b
and then put that at the front of my
sequence so i just dropped the last
letter
and my sequence becomes b b r
i'll show you another example if keanu
had chosen red red red
then i would have just changed that
middle r to a b
put that at the beginning of my sequence
drop the last
r and my sequence would be b r
r just that little trick allows me to
have an advantage anywhere from about
two to one up to seven point five
to one which means in the worst possible
scenario
for me i win 2 out of 3 times
and in the best it's nearly 8 out of 9.
look i'll write out all the choice
options and their odds
as player 2 when we apply the algorithm
where jumping
into exactly the right place in a cycle
of outcomes that
player 1 doesn't have any control over
the best
player 1 can do is choose an option
that's
the least bad how is this
possible how can i take something so
seemingly fair to both players so
obviously 50 50 and turn it so strongly
in my
favor the key is in recognizing that
this game is non-transitive
so there you go the end
wait what is transitive think of it this
way you've got
a b and c a beats b
and b beat c therefore a beats c
because if a beats b and b beats c then
obviously a
can beat c that game is transitive
so if you and your keanu oops had
transitive food preferences you'd rather
have
pizza than tacos and you'd rather have
tacos than
dog food you'd also rather have pizza
than dog food simple if you and your
kianu
somehow preferred dog food to pizza
then all of a sudden your food
preferences become
non-transitive in a non-transitive game
there is no
best choice for the first player because
there's no super
powered a instead there's a loop of
winning choices
like rock paper scissors in rock paper
scissors rock which we'll call
a loses to paper which we'll call b
b is better than a but a beats
scissors which is c so a is better than
c but b loses to c
so c is better than b and paper b beats
rock a
so b is better than a scissors c
loses to rock a and beats paper b
and we've got a loop of possible
outcomes that
goes on forever with no one choice being
stronger
than the other that's non-transitive
since we're in the flow chart mode
here's a flow chart that illustrates the
player two winning moves
in the humble nishiyama randomness game
so if you follow the arrows you can see
that
rbb beats bbb and like
bbr beats brb and so forth
with the odds added you can clearly see
how some
sequence scenarios go from bad to worse
in the humble nishiyama randomness
variation of pennies game we
know what sequence of card colors player
1 has chosen first so
we can jump in the most advantageous
part of the non-transitive loop and make
a choice that gives us a significant
advantage by recognizing that the game
is
non-transitive we can take seemingly
obvious fairness and find a paradoxical
loophole
that nearly guarantees us success to
everyone who doesn't recognize the
intransitivity it just
kind of looks like we're extremely lucky
and
why does all of this matter because
bacteria play rock paper scissors to
multiply
benjamin kirkup and margaret riley found
that bacteria compete with one another
in a non-transitive way they found that
in mice intestines
e coli bacteria formed a competitive
cycle
in which three strains basically played
a game of rock paper scissors to survive
and find an equilibrium penny's game and
its variations illustrate how even
a scenario that seems perfectly
straightforward
like unmistakably simple should never be
taken
at face value there's always room to
develop
strategize and improve our odds if we
put
in the effort and imagination required
to understanding the situation
and that truly is
breathtaking and as always thanks for
[Music]
watching